the internet revolution has allowed
things to happen more cheaply and more
openly by creating the web and internet
and other things but one of the things
that's causing a lot of friction and a
lot of failure right now in the system
is that copyright is very complex and
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to make copyright as seamless and easy
and low-cost and simple as the other
layers of the Internet have done for
information technology and hopefully
this will cause a kind of explosion of
innovation just like the web did and
just like the internet did and Creative
Commons is trying to help those tools
with those